[Music]
chuck
uh what's happening neil i think i've
run out of explainers
no no never that's never gonna happen
how do you how do you know
what i tell you and now you tell me no
because
you're an inexhaustible source of
information
so that's and and people i don't know
i don't want to be the source of
information i want to be the source of
wisdom
well you know you have that too
occasionally
well all right so it's the end of the
year
and i mean i could just talk about end
of the year stuff
okay so should i do that final thoughts
on the end of your final thoughts
all right uh so we lost alex trebek
oh yeah so that's sad uh pancreatic
cancer he lived a full life and an
important life and
touched so many people so if you're
gonna die
make sure people um that the world is a
little different in a better way for you
having been in it and he certainly
fulfilled that
so alex trebek the world looking for
ants arrested he was the man who had all
the questions
right and the man who created a safe
space
for geeks for more than three decades
so so and even before it was cool to be
geek he was doing it
so yeah yeah but anyhow just uh
christmas week
uh the excuse me the the days leading up
to christmas
over that set of days you may have
noticed that jupiter and saturn were
nearing each other in the sky
and they got really close they got
really close so close that if your
vision is sort of
okay not entirely good you would think
they were one object on the sky
they have not been seen to be that close
to each other
since the year 12 20
12 26. really yes okay
actually they were that close to uh
together in 1623
galileo might have seen it however they
got that close together but they were
near the sun and so you might have lost
it in the glare
all right so the last time it was down
dark enough to see it was 800 freaking
years ago
wow so i told everybody about it i hope
people got to see it
and um and people say
where do i find jupiter and saturn
they're right next to each other
[Laughter]
well that's because everybody you know
everybody knows venus because it's
so so bright often mistaken for a ufo
because it's a bright light hovering
over the horizon
in the different colors of twilight okay
aliens visiting uh so so there's that
that was a nice little astronomical
event to to to bring the year to a close
uh so then we have what's going on now
so these are the shortest days of the
year in the northern hemisphere
shortest right length of daylight and
so the sun is what heats earth
so if on your way into the first day of
winter december 21st
you're getting less and less sunlight
chances are it's going to get colder and
colder and colder and that's what
happens
that's why that happens okay we have
less sun not only is the sun not in the
sky
as long the angle in the sky is lower
lower all right so here's something you
might not have known
people talk about high noon okay those
two words together
imply like where's the sun at 12 noon
oh that kind of high oh
i'm sorry
i was someplace totally different
so you're thinking like straight up
right
and so on december 21st
the sun from the latitude of new york
city
mack the maximum high in the sky it gets
is an angle of 26 degrees above the
horizon
straight up is 90 degrees 90. halfway
is is 45 degrees you know nearly half
that again 20 60 degrees there
that's the highest the sun gets at 12
noon on december
21st oh wow so
so that's that's why things get colder
and the farther north you go the lower
the sun
is right and the shorter it is in the
sky
my wife is from alaska did someone just
come up for a couple hours and then set
again
and the rest of the day everybody okay
all right give me the sun just check it
out buddy okay
all right see you guys later let me just
pop my hand up
and then maybe just the eyes okay am i
good okay i'll be back later
if the sun could talk that's what i
would be saying um and of course the
inverse of that is happening south of
the equator where
in alaska depending on the day and what
your latitude is
you could have 22 hours of dark and two
hours of sunlight
the inverse of that is happening on that
very same day in the southern hemisphere
if you go very far
south so in the arctic ocean
antarctic areas you you would have
in december you'd have 22 hours of light
and only two hours of darkness
so it's a symmetric ballet between what
the
sun light and darkness is doing and
if it's always the opposite from one
side of the earth to the other
then what's it doing on the equator hmm
it's it's just there
does it not count as an authentic answer
on a science
f f for that answer
okay the equator is the perpetual middle
of everything right okay so we have long
days and short nights and then
short days and long nights and the
opposite
on the equator is 12 hours of day and
night every single day
of the year sweet they are the middle
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter yeah
because everything is switching
it's symmetrically on either side of the
equator north and south of the equator
so it's it's it's the fulcrum and the
seesaw doesn't make it different oh good
i like that the fulcrum
very nice or if you're not physics
literate just the balance point
of the song fulcrum you're showing off
chuck okay
so now let's keep going so we now go to
uh new year's eve december 31st
um and then uh by the way
we think you know i don't mean to you
know
diss the habits and rituals of
civilization
but new year's eve everyone is
celebrating the moment
that it hits midnight
but it hits midnight in 24
different time zones across 24 hours
so what you think is the special moment
happening in some cosmic calendrical way
is not it's smeared out
over all 24 time zones of the world
so you know just just relax
okay wow man i can't believe you just
ruined new year's eve i'm just saying
everybody said come down to that last
second and in that second then you kiss
and then you drink champagne in that
moment and then
and then meanwhile central time zone
it's still 11 o'clock
and mountain time is 10 and in l.a it's
still 9pm
okay and in fact we get new year's
new year's moment first okay right la
where they have new year's rock and eve
they have bands performing
and they're celebrating midnight for us
because it's 9 p.m there all right
they're people
only just arriving for their nighttime
activities
so the whole thing is a charade it's a
time zone charade
that's all i don't mean you know to be
like the grinch new year's grinch
but i'm just just telling you just i got
you i mean
yeah it's i mean i get it it's a little
disney like
okay okay now they have new year's eve
every night
speaking of ritualistic celebrations um
uh in a few years before uh peter
jennings the
the the well-known abc news anchor
uh he decided to do a 24-hour
new year's eva thon okay and the way he
was going to do this he was going to
start
a 24-hour news broadcast
at the first time zone that celebrates
the new year
and he had correspondents in nearly all
time zones
uh delivering their story and so
he invited me in for a several of those
hours to comment on just the cosmic
phenomenon that's happening okay and so
there and then we got to europe because
they get it five hours before we do
and this just kept moving then
they went to antarctica where every year
there's a stick that indicates the south
pole
and then they move it to the new
location of the south pole
and and it's a big ritual they all
gather whoever's in the south pole at
the time
they gathered four of them oh four
people
all four people get together and the
penguins they all just gone over
and by the way so in antarctica in
december it's broad daylight
okay because that's the opposite side of
the world and there they're far enough
south
the south pole that they have 24 hours
of light so it makes a good
media moment so there they are they're
shifting the south pole
and then i now as an educator i care
that people know what the hell is going
on
if you're demonstrating it and none of
them they're all scientists
none of them explained why they had to
shift the pole
right it's like is something wrong with
the earth can someone please explain oh
my gosh what happened
what what it's what okay so there's a
reason for it
please okay because i don't know this no
no no no this okay i did not know this
so in this ritual so you can you can get
the survey
knowledge and okay so they have to shift
it because
the what we say is the land mass of
antarctica
is beneath ice glacial ice
and all this ice is moving a glacier is
a solid river
if you want to think about in fluid
terms glaciers are always moving
and so the glacier on which you put the
stick
over the year has moved it has flowed
towards its
towards its destination and i don't
forget exactly where the south pole
point is going probably directly towards
the sea the ocean
okay so they figure out what that is
they pick it up replant it
and there it is for another year that
happens every year at the south pole
in antarctica yeah and happens every
year
uh for the next few years in which case
there will be no more ice okay and we
won't have to worry about it
particularly worried about santa claus
up on the north pole because there's no
land there at all it's just ice flows
it's just ice it's not even ice flowing
on on
on land it's ice f-l-o-e
it's floating ice icebergs basically
so any tv show and i knew this was a kid
any tv show
that shows santa's workshop on the north
pole with trees and mountains trees
no no oh man
my boy is floating on ice thank you all
right
and that's why he needs reindeer to fly
off the office island
off his ice island but anyhow
if i take you to the south pole and we
just sort of sit around the south pole
you sit down and i sit down and the cell
pulls between us and i say chuck
go north my son
okay
which direction is that oh wow
because we're both we're hm any direct
any direction
so it means get the hell out of here
just leave is what you're saying
on the south pole there is no east or
west there is only north
only north oh wow that's cool right
right
and that's what that's what led to the
old um brain teaser it's
uh you tell someone to go uh 10 miles
due north 10 miles due east due east
and then 10 miles due south again and
you end up right back where you started
right where are you you're you're on the
south pole
south pole right yeah because on the
with that's one of your vortices what
looks like making sort of direct right
angles they're not really right angles
they're
you you just mapped out a triangle right
on a curved
geometry and this is something that
euclid hadn't thought about
and so in fact it's called non-euclidean
geometry
sweet yeah yeah so non-remember you
learned parallel lines
quote meat at infinity or whatever you
might well they never meet okay
right they never mean that they meet
okay two power lines on
a curved surface such as the surface of
the earth
have to meet okay so the rules are
different
all right and the the sum of the angles
of a triangle come to 180 degrees
on a curved surface the sum of the
angles of a triangle are always more
than 180 degrees
and in fact you can make a triangle with
three right angles
so be nine to 270 degrees so so all the
geometry is different it's called
non-euclidean geometry it's a great
discovery
that then albert einstein absorbed up
into his general theory of relativity
it's very cool but now if it's at the
south pole it's called
non-chuck nice geometry because children
will never find my black behind
at the south pole period
[Laughter]
that is true i don't know it's that you
know is it really an ethnic thing
i've well okay this is funny we say this
because you're right i've never
looked at the south pole and seeing
people um
whatever the i say gee i wish i were
there that was just that's never been a
thought
it's funny you and i say this because
this distaste for extremely cold
environments
because um matthew henson was black
and he was with uh robert perry when
they went and discovered the north pole
and first to go to the north pole
and he didn't know where they were going
who didn't know
matthew henson was just like man where
are we
no but he he he actually established
relations with the
with the inuits uh so that they could
help navigate and know where they're
going and how they're going to get there
so it was quite the cul the collab
so chuck one last thing i want to tell
you just as we close out the year
the first week of january earth in its
oval orbit
around the sun okay finds itself
at its closest point to the sun and it's
it and it's called
perihelion perihelion so i always wanted
shirts to say mary perihelion
all right because it's that time it's
still the holiday season uh it's before
the three kings day which is january 6th
which concludes the 12 days of christmas
from christmas day
to january 6 when the three kings
arrived apparently not on the day jesus
was born we are told uh 12 days later so
uh i don't know what held them up i
don't know what the problem was they had
the star to guide them
you know right i don't know what the
problem was tough tough getting the
camera
the ubers weren't running uber's very
difficult to find that thing
so uh so they're a helium so they're
right after festival so it's a it's a
it's an astronomical
time of the uh moment that that that we
celebrate okay uh wow it's the most
astronomic
and of course since we're closest to the
sun but the northern hemisphere it's the
dead of winter
clearly our distance from the sun is not
what's giving us our seasons
and the seasons come from the tilt of
the earth's axis
relative to the sun and that's a whole
other explainer video that we could do
if we wanted to
so that's all i got for you at the end
of the year chuck but so well
happy new year to you and happy
perihelion
let's hope that 2021 does a little
better for the world
than the 2020 did um i don't like
pandemics i like to think we're beyond
such things
yeah and you know the whole point of
star talk is to
bring a little science into people's
lives and have them smile while they do
it
and some of that science is matters to
your health your health and
wealth and well-being and and security
so
uh anyhow that's what we do chuck always
a pleasure happy new year to you and
happy new year to all
fans and supporters and even if you're a
casual listen to
listener of what we do here um hope you
appreciate it and maybe even become a
patreon member
um we'd love them especially because
chuck uh
praises the money they give us that's it
that's why i love you same reason i love
my wife oh she's
she's paying the rent she's still giving
me money man because this comedy thing
is still trying you still trying to make
this
i'm trying to make it a comedy but thank
god for that
all right chuck happy new year happy new
year as always
near the grass tyson bidding you to keep
looking up
especially in 2021.